meine damen und herren
vielleicht war es grey's anatomie house
of cards oder derzeit die serie
seitentriebe meine heutigen gäste wissen
warum serien zur droge werden
die sind da ist autorin und regisseurin
von seitentriebe einer serie über 6 oder
besser über die abwesenheit von 6 in
langen beziehung helaba tianyi ist autor
der serie wilder ein mystischer krimi
über die dunklen geheimnisse eines
schweizer berggipfels und schließlich
bettina aber sie leitet die serien für
srf und hat jahrelang den bestatter
begleitet gemeinsam möchten wir heute
einen gesellschaftlichen mega phänomen
auf den grund gehen das seit jahren
boomt sie heißen house of cards breaking
bad oder orange ist in new black serien
auf der internetplattform netflix knapp
900 verschiedene serien bietet der
streamingdienst momentan an und es
werden immer mehr und sie werden immer
aufwändiger produziert house of cards zb
kostete netflix 60 millionen dollar pro
staffel
das zahlt sich aus denn auch die zahl
der nutzer steigt konstant waren es im
jahr 2010 noch 19 millionen angemeldete
haushalte sind es 2015 bereits 70
millionen nun anfang 2018 sind 118
millionen haushalte angemeldet und wir
schauen viel vor eineinhalb jahren
wurden deutsche die serien schauen
gefragt wie häufig sie das tun
weit über die hälfte der befragten
schaut täglich oder fast täglich serien
wie ist dieser erfolg zu erklären was
fasziniert uns so an serien dass wir
immer mehr freizeit mit ihnen verbringen
constantin seibt journalist und
mitgründer des online-magazins republik
wenn es sich für irgendetwas lohnt im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert bis jetzt
gelebt zu haben dann sind da schon die
fernsehserien sind einfach von einer
komplexität von einer tiefe von einer
schönheit und von einer melancholie die
es vorher so nicht gegeben hat ja für
serien lohnt es sich zu leben werden sie
das auch sagen frage ich hätte es nicht
so schön sagen können wie constantin
seibt aber es hat schon was vielleicht
wenn man es nicht ganz so pathetisch
ausdrückt weil wir machen sie ja wir
dürfen ja nicht ganz so pathetisch reden
würde ich sagen ja doch die die
schönheit und die melancholie die kam
tatsächlich noch mal neu zurück mit
denen sie ihren das glaube ich
und um schönheit und melancholie geht's
ja im ganzen leben über das möchten wir
noch ein bisschen resultiert warum lohnt
es sich für sie eine serie zu schauen
ich schaue sehr gerne serien weil ich
sehr gerne eintauchen
weil ich sehr gerne ein paar tisch fühle
mit den figuren mit gehe die die figuren
werden teil meines alltags ich freue
mich auf eine auf eine nächste episode
ich freue mich auch mit zu denken was
passieren könnte von einer episode zur
nächsten also dass ein bedürfnis auch
nach dieser komplexität und
vielschichtigkeit die mich reinzieht und
und die mich bewegt und ich glaube
bewegt sein ist so ein gefühl das
eigentlich ein großes bedürfnis ist ich
glaube dass möchten sehr viel geld leute
gerne tun ich war früher mehr im kino
aus als heute
leider aber wenn ich früher ins kino
ging dann saß ich sehr gerne alleine da
weil ich diese gefühle dann eigentlich
stärker ausleben konnte also wenn ich
mit freunden oder so ging und das kann
ich jetzt mit serien eigentlich sehr gut
machen weil ich kann mich verkriechen in
mein zimmer und abtauchen genau und
mitfühlen
und das ist für mich eigentlich so
überhaupt beweggründe
was ist für sie das faszinierende an
serien ich kann mich eigentlich da dem
bett ja nur anschließen das ist wirklich
das eintauchen in fremde welten in
ganzen kosmos in familien von figuren
mit denen man wirklich lebt die ein
begleitet von denen man im extremfall
manchmal sogar träumt und das tolle sind
ist die vielfalt an geschichten und ich
habe als kind immer schon gerne
geschichten gehabt und das schönste war
wenn es lang war als wenn es nicht
aufgehört hat und serien versprechen so
ein bisschen dieses es geht weiter man
kann dranbleiben es gibt also es kommt
noch mehr
und es ist immer schwer also beim
langenbuch weil ich habe mal gern die
dickste normale gehabt und es gab immer
die angst dass die geschichte bald zu
ende ist und bei serien ist es ganz
ähnlich dieses ich mag nicht gerne
abschied nehmen von figuren darum ist
serie
das ist zwar der logik der serie
eingeschrieben dass es immer weitergeht
und dass man eintauchen kann
die philosophin susanne schmetkamp hat
mal gesagt eigentlich hinter diesem
suchtfaktor von serien steckt eine
sehnsucht nämlich die sehnsucht nach
geborgenheit nachher nach heimat nach
kontinuität sinken sehen sie das ähnlich
ist das wirklich ein haupt bewegung zu
was das ist der absolute hauptbeweggrund
weil es gibt einen entscheidenden
unterschied ob man ob man ins kino geht
und in einem film eintaucht oder ein
buch liest und in diese geschichte
eintaucht was man in der serie macht
indem man eine serie schaut ist man
schaut gleichzeitig allein mit sich auf
dem laptop und gleichzeitig nicht allein
in der gemeinschaft man sucht sich die
leute die diese serie auch gesehen haben
und man sucht ja auch sofort nach diesen
leuten man geht auf twitter bei tatort
ist es ganz extrem
die schauen gleichzeitig den tatort um
twittern live was sie sehen so ich
glaube dass hier eine art gemeinschaft
hergestellte die so vorher nicht gab es
ist eine mischung aus social media und
serien schauen oder vielleicht auch
ausgehen und ich merke schon dass die
leute sich als teil dieser familie
fühlen dieser gemeinschaft ich habe ja
sonst wenig wenn ich fernsehe nicht fern
sie habe ich ja nicht dass ich teil der
tagesschau das passiert ja nicht aber
bei einer serie passiert das sehr
schnell deswegen sucht man sich leute
die in der gleichen staffel noch sind
mann fragte wer guckt die erste staffel
und wer guckt die zweite die sind dann
nicht so spannend
das heißt es wird so eine virtuelle
gemeinschaft gesucht von leuten die sich
mit einem über diese serien unterhalten
obwohl jeder alleine schaut entspannt
war diese communitys diese gemeinschaft
ist einerseits eine von mit
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer die diese
auch sehen aber andererseits auch mit
den figuren selbst werden auch so was
wie eine ersatzfamilie fascht e familie
könnte man vielleicht sagen also
psychologinnen und psychologen sprechen
von pará sozialen beziehungen also ich
kenne diese para sozialen beziehungen
sehr gut aber vor allem als autor weil
ich natürlich mit meinen figuren ständig
lebe und auf der straße auch über sie
nachdenken
interessanterweise habe ich glaube ich
beim schauen nicht also ich bin
eigentlich froh wenn draußen zu stehen
und eben mitzufühlen also das gefühl mit
zu fühlen gibt mir auch die distanz zu
sagen das bin nicht ich
aber das ist eine person mit der ich mit
vielen möchte und dieses gefühl von
dieses mitgefühl ist eigentlich das was
was was mich am stärksten bewegt und
nicht das gefühl selbst diese figur zu
sein also ich möchte nicht mit den
figuren verschmelzen ich möchte wissen
dass das diese figuren aus dieser
geschichte sind aber ich lebe
anstelle von ihnen diese gefühle mit für
mich ich meine wir leben in zeiten wo so
atomisierten individuum umherirren in
dieser welt jeder für sich in sehr
individualistisch und ich habe das
gefühl man kennt die serienfiguren
manchmal besser aus die eigenen nachbarn
oder die eigenen freunde man weiß alles
über die wenn man nicht sechs staffeln
gesehen hat ja ich glaube es ist eben
schon dieses manchmal leben die figuren
auch was für ein
das ist dass es so ein bisschen ab wo
ich mich manchmal auch frage ist es gut
dass ich so da eintauchen und rhein
gezogen werde und selber eigentlich das
erlebnis gar nicht in meinem wirklichen
leben so sehr habe sondern
gibt's ab an den an denen man die figur
und wer ist auch mal ist manchmal bin
ich natürlich auch wahnsinnig
erleichtert wenn es zum beispiel game of
thrones ist oder so dass irgendjemand
für mich diese figur endlich recht hätte
ich das nicht selber machen muss im
wahren leben also dass ich nicht ein
krieg führen muss den ich ja mal auf dem
bildschirm sehe dass es die faszination
von diesen geschichten dass man glaube
ich auch was man lernt aus den
geschichten einerseits was für sich und
andererseits ist man doch emotional
man hat starke emotionen auch beim
anschauen aber die hat man doch nur weil
man sich identifizieren kann ich gehe
arbeiten bestimmte aspekte müssten da
akzentuiert seien in diesen figuren die
man selbst ich glaube dass sich dass ich
das im moment sehr stark wandelt es war
ja früher hat man ja so geschrieben als
mann für spielfilme geschrieben hat noch
oder die klassischen serien die ihr also
jetzt die man kennt aus dem
vorabendprogramm oder so hat man ja so
geschrieben dass man die
identifikationsfiguren benannt hat und
auch quasi genau so kreiert hat das ist
die identifikationsfigur und irgendwie
die frauen dass ich die für die männer
und das ist jetzt unsere hauptsächliche
identifikationsfigur das ist bei den
modernen serien nicht mehr so das ist
nicht so dass man sich eine figur aus
nimmt und die ist es dann für 1 also all
in the new black beste beispiel
vielleicht braucht es diese weiße frau
aus guter mittelschicht die ja in dieses
amerikanische gefängnis eintaucht wo sie
all diesen verschiedenen identitäten
gegenüber steht und das wird ja amerika
gesellschaft noch mal ganz neu auf
aufgeräumt aufgerollt und da ist es dann
sehr schnell dass man sich nicht mehr
mit der hauptfigur identifiziert sondern
sich seine lieblingsfiguren in diesem
gefängnis sucht das muss so sein das ist
bei uns jetzt auch so ich habe diesmal
beim schreiben auch gemerkt dass die
identifikation anders funktionieren du
brauchst quasi nicht mehr diese eine
hauptfigur die für dich durch die
geschichte geht bei gamern songs okay da
ist es logisch weil es die art
geschichte da gibt es auch viele glaube
ich wirklich auch darum dass es
ensemble ist das ist ein figuren
geschlecht ist das nicht nur eine figur
sind viele es sind beziehungen es sind
figuren die aufeinander reagieren und
die figuren selbst sind auch
vielschichtig es gibt nicht einfach nur
den einen helden sondern es gibt einfach
die haben alle verletzungen erlebt die
haben ja ihre ihre wunden natürlich wenn
man dann die figuren kreiert aber die
machen auch fehler und das macht das
macht sie so nahbar man so wieder
erkennbar und an dem in den momenten hat
das mit uns selbst was zu tun wir sind
es lange nicht perfekt das ist ja das
spannende am 19
dass man viel mehr zeit hat die figuren
zu entwickeln wir dürfen eine viel
größere spannweite und da macht man dann
solche experimente wie man verwandelt
den protagonisten in einen antagonisten
oder umgekehrt also und es geht auf
beide arten weil man natürlich auch nähe
schafft zu dieser figur weil man seine
schwächen kennen lernt weil man diese
schwächen auch ausbauen muss ist klar
das ist auch der spaß am tanzen und
plötzlich wird ein am anfang an ein
unsympathischer oder ein bösewicht kann
dann plötzlich zu einem sehr zu einer
sehr nahen figur kommt dessen dessen
beweggründe man dann auch versteht und
diese person wächst dann wirklich ans
herz und dann sieht man plötzlich die
ganze dann verändert sich die
perspektive und ich glaube das ist auch
ein teil dieser so wird das wäre nicht
fair
entschuldigung man fürchtete zum teil
für die figuren man hat langsam simon
man will hat wünsche und hoffnungen für
sie also so stark involviert man sich
dann gibt es aber doch glaube ich etwas
das darüber hinausgeht das war die
klassische art der identifikation mit
den figuren aber ich habe bei mir
gemerkt dass ich sehr stark auf eine
zweite neue für mich neue art
identifikation funktionieren ich habe
die deutschen ihre tag geschaut nicht
sehr mochte die hat mich sehr
reingezogen und da sind die permanent
alle irgendwie in gefahr
und irgendwann war es mir egal wer als
nächstes stirbt ich wollte einfach
wissen was ist da los warum sterben die
alle ich wollte das große geheimnis
gelöst wissen aber es war nicht so dass
ich die ganze zeit angst hatte weg
könnte jetzt als nächster stärken
ich hatte das akzeptiert jetzt stirbt
das ist neu für mich weil ich ja sonst
doch
ja ich jetzt als zuschauerin als normale
zuschauerin die das filmwissen ablegt
doch immer so meine figuren hat um die
ich litt und um die ich angst hatte und
ich fand es sehr interessant dass also
sogar der tod von protagonisten etwas
ganz neues bedeuten kann das war vorher
tabu einer früheren sie ihren konzepten
was tabu naja und die helden sterben ja
dann einfach weg bei game of thrones so
zum beispiel und auch bei anderen serien
möchten gehen nämlich den faktor zeit
also die neuen tv serien werden ja oft
mit
wie gesagt das ist der roman des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts man kann
eben vielschichtige figuren erzählen
mehrere figuren erzählen kollektiv
erzählen wie sie gesagt haben
entwicklungen nachzeichnen dass jemand
sozusagen auf die böse seite wechsels
von der macht korrumpiert wird usw
da habe ich mich gefragt wenn diese
neuen serien psychologisch tiefer sehen
könnte man sagen wir da ein neues
menschenbild transportiert im gegensatz
zu früher wo man so schematisch gut und
böse hatte ja ich würde sagen unsere
welt ist sehr komplex und wir nehmen sie
auch als was komplexes war und
dementsprechend spiegeln serien diese
das spiegelt sich in den serien durch
komplexe figuren die nicht einfach
schwarz weiß sind und auch keine
einfachen antworten haben auf die fragen
denen wir uns allen ausgesetzt sehen
tagtäglich aber warum dieses phänomen
heute warum also ich meine die sehnsucht
nach nach einer abbildung der realität
nach dem einfachen von komplexität von
entwicklungen vielschichtigen für sie
gab es auch schon immer warum jetzt
heute genau dieser begriff also
also ich glaube es hat sich auch damit
zu tun dass eben aus einem rein
wirtschaftlichen aspekt heraus dass
diese pay tv ist in amerika gestartet
sind vor gut 15 20 jahren und dadurch
einfach der markt stärker wurde und
dadurch auch die konkurrenz und dadurch
wurden die stoffe spannender komplexer
vielschichtiger virtuose und das hat das
ganze belebt man spricht ja auch vom
golden age of television also sowas gab
es ja auch noch nicht
das ist ja tatsächlich eine neue
erscheinung und und aber wie sie sagen
also der wunsch nach komplexität oder
der wunsch nach starken geschichten das
bedürfnis nach solchen geschichten der
ist natürlich uhr also das fängt am
lagerfeuer an das ist nichts neues aber
ich denke schon dass man weggeht von
dieser betrachtung des einfachen helden
der immer gleich ist er eben nicht
stirbt der ein ein sicherer wert hin zu
geschichten wo sich mehr fragen auftun
wo man auch gerne mal die seite wechselt
wo man gerne mal vielleicht auch in die
abgründe der protagonisten schaut und
auch angezogen ist von diesen schwächen
weil wir ja selbst diese schwächen auch
haben und diese figuren sind eigentlich
auch so ein bisschen stellvertreter
figuren die diese emotionen zum teil für
uns übernehmen die wir uns selbst gar
nicht getrauen zu übernehmen also
manchmal ist man ja froh dass diese
person jetzt dass durch das läuft ja
weil wir das vielleicht gar nicht können
oder es dockt an etwas an das wir gar
nicht kannten ja aber das stichwort ab
grünen das interessant weil das ist mir
in der vorbereitung aufgefallen ich bin
jetzt kein leidenschaftlicher serien
gucken aber wenn man irgendwie breaking
bad oder house of cards game of thrones
derweil und so weit dass browns da geht
es irgendwie um macht da geht es um
drogen und gewalt und die den reiz des
bösen
warum was zu etwas das gut das sind
natürlich die flaggschiffe die sehr
teuren teuer produzierten serien die ein
möglichst großes mainstream publikum
herein holen sollen ich glaube dass die
eher klassischer funktionieren sogar
aber es gibt ja dann eben die anderen
geschichten die kleineren die eben auch
zielgruppenspezifischer agieren
das war ja vielleicht eine der ganz
großen neuerungen dieser bezahlsender
wie netflix dass die sagen konnten wir
machen teure flaggschiffe macht leisten
uns aber auch kleinere zielgruppen
spezifischere dinge und ich finde das
was da passiert im moment sehr viel
interessanter das nämlich plötzlich ganz
viele afroamerikanische
schauspielerinnen und schauspieler
auftauchen dass plötzlich die rollen
überhaupt nicht mehr so vergeben werden
wie früher
und dass man leute sieht die man so in
den klassischen serien bis vor kurzem
nicht gesehen hatte das hat natürlich
auch wirtschaftliche gründe weil erstens
die leute dann ja lieber weil sie sich
mit denen identifizieren es gibt ja ganz
viele dunkelhäutige leute in amerika
außerdem kannst es besser verkaufen ins
ausland verkaufen und das fand ich das
finde ich im moment die wesentlich
spannendere entwicklung von wegen
menschenbild es ging ja darum was wird
hier von menschen will wie ihr das wird
kreiert dass man nämlich plötzlich abend
aha die helden die die leute die durch
die filme laufen
die schäden sind die müssen nicht alle
weißen blond sein
es ginge auch anders sparen und auch
mehr pluralismus mehr vielfalt inhalt es
wirklich das stichwort also vielfalt das
ist auch dass man muss sich einerseits
auch die sender müssen sich abgrenzen
mit den serien die sie erfinden wie sie
ausstrahlen das heißt es muss
unterscheidbar sein muss was besonderes
sein es muss was muss eine gewisse
originalität auch haben und dass es für
die kreativen ein geschenk weil das
extrem anregend ist mein vielfalt
gefragt zum beispiel bei haut sondern
der großartigen sondern da spielen ja
praktisch alle wichtigen rollen sind ja
von lateinamerikanischen amerikanern
oder von von afroamerikanischen
amerikanern gespielt wenn es gibt
natürlich weiß auch mit drin aber das
ist so umgedreht in dem moment und man
merkt es nicht
man setzt sich nicht hinter k h da will
man mir was verkauft es ist so normal
und dann denkt man ja stimmt das ist ja
eigentlich auch noch mal und dass das
jemand als völlig normal ansieht und das
auch nicht thematisiert wird in der
serie
das finde ich
grandios und ich behaupte dass solche
dinge mehr das menschenbild machen für
die veränderung des serien menschen will
es machen als wenn man sich hinstellen
würde und ein zehn punkte programm wie
man jetzt diese menschen besser
integrieren könnte innerhalb des filmes
ich liebe solche entwicklungen ich
beobachte die mit großer freude grad
gleichzeitig könnte man etwas skeptisch
oder ketzerisch sagen die serie
verkörpert das grundprinzip des
kapitalismus nämlich immer mehr die ja
man muss immer weiter gucken mal kann es
ganz individuell für sich dosieren und
konsumieren was halten sie von dieser
these ausspielen als serienstar hier ist
das natürlich schwer zu sagen aber es
stimmt schon das ist auch das ist
vielleicht ein bisschen anderer gedanke
aber was man eben auch merkt das angebot
von von serien ist groß es ist
reichhaltig es wird immer größer das ist
toll
andererseits merkt man eben auch gerade
diese plattformen ich sehe das selber
wenn ich anfange netflix zu gucken und
ich habe zwei serien geschaut
zweimal ein krimi geschaut dann wird mir
netflix die nächsten male den nächsten
krimi anbieten das heißt meine meine
sehgewohnheiten oder meine meine ja das
was ich am meisten schauen oder was
viele andere am meisten schauen wird
immer stärker ausgewählt und mir als
dass das wirklich auch interessieren
präsentiert das heißt auf der einen
seite gibt es diese wahnsinnige viel
fand wo man wo man auch was über die
welt lernen kann über andere welten und
kann israelische türkische
brasilianische man kann serien aus aller
welt gucken und andererseits dampft es
dann doch sehr schnell wieder was ein wo
man denkt okay sind dass die zwei seiten
wo es am schluss der totalitarismus da
ist oder der kapitalismus sich als es
dann wirklich nur noch das ja was ist
dass wir alle sehen wollen also die ich
weiß es nicht
diese filter blasen dies bei den medien
gibt sozialen medien gibt es dann
vielleicht acht bei den serien waren wir
nur diese vorgeschlagen werden von denen
der algorithmus weiß dass ich dir gerne
sehen möchten das kann man aber umgehend
auf netflix kann man das sogar ein
algorithmus ja aber wie viele machen das
aber du hast ja die frage ist wie es du
nun gehen ist es die ganze wohl damit
wenn du einstellt wenn du es nicht wenn
du weißt es wird die wieder was
präsentiert wurde wirst du groß suchen
muss aber ich würde auch sagen dass es
dinge zu entdecken gibt sogar durch den
durch den ganz normalen gran sogar durch
die sachen die vorgeschlagen er gleich
zum stichwort sehgewohnheiten auch hier
haben sich denn diese verändert also ich
habe mir im vorgespräch gesagt die
pausen zb sind ganz wichtig zwischen den
einzelnen fragen warum ja anders als im
kino wo man reingeht und und zwei
stunden lang beschäftigt ist mit dem
film und zum teil gar keine zeit hatte
eigene gedanken zu machen bieten
natürlich die pausen diese zwischenzeit
zwischen zwei episoden natürlich die
möglichkeit geben aktiv oder interaktiv
einzusteigen mitzudenken sich
vorzustellen antizipieren was vielleicht
passieren könnte und ich glaube das
macht einen großen teil der sogwirkung
aus dass wir voraus denken können was
denn jetzt noch kommen könnte und auch
fast schon mit wünschen mit hoffen wie
es den figuren gehen soll
und wenn wir das dann in der
gemeinschaft austauschen dann ist das
auch so identitätsstiftend dann kommen
die leute zusammen und besprechen das
gemeinsame und das ist sicher auch das
geht wieder zurück in diese frage was
sie uns gibt und es gibt halt auch halt
das gibt gemeinschaft ich würde sogar so
weit gehen dass es gibt es gibt eine art
inspiration auch und ein funke der
manchmal auch ausgelöst wird in unserer
welt in der alles so vorbestimmt ist und
und gespachtelt ist es manchmal auch
schön so ein funken von inspiration zu
spülen und damit gefühle zuzulassen
aber ich meine dieses ganze phänomen der
portionierung einer geschichte ist ja
nicht neu es gab diese fortsetzungsroman
im neunzehnten jahrhundert wo liegen die
wurzeln
es fängt das schon ganz früh an es gibt
ja die geschichte von scherz gerade die
um ihr leben erzählt also die wirklich
namen abend für abend im sultan glaube
ich dass nächste märchen erzählt und an
der spannendsten stelle aufhören dann
weiß sie morgen abend wird sie wieder
geholt
doping ist oder cliffhanger es wirklich
nur erfindungen genau was ich noch
interessant findest zu den
sehgewohnheiten ist ich glaube dass auch
die möglichkeit die folgen jetzt alle
hintereinander weg zu sehen auch das hat
weder diese zwei seiten von eintauchen
tiefer eintauchen vertrauter werden mit
den figuren mit dieser welt aber
gleichzeitig natürlich auch der aspekt
der betäubung also dass sich wegschießen
was meinst lenkung mit seinem er also
fast eine sucht weil wir auch von sucht
zum teil regen dann redet ja kurz gesagt
von diesem bild roger mason koma klotzen
wie man comma soft kamera kann man auch
lausanne glotzen genau die anfragen auf
jeden fall
und auf der anderen seite ist es aber
natürlich auch wiederum dass ich glaube
dass die möglichkeit die folgen
hintereinander so anzuschauen auch
wiederum das erzählen beflügelt hat man
kann jetzt eben auch komplexe erzählen
früher musste man
wenn man zb noch youtube blogs oder weiß
ich noch genau das kam woche für woche
und man musste bei der folge für jedes
mal wieder noch mal in erinnerung rufen
was letztes mal passiert war und zwar in
den dialogen nicht in form von rieck
apps oder so wie man das heute zum teil
macht und das heißt dadurch dass man
alles gucken kann kann man auch alles
also mit man es hat einem es hat auch
erzählen das erzählen befreit
es hat auch das ermöglicht dass man
anspruchsvoller erzählen kann
und entgegen entgegen eigentlich unserer
schnelllebigen zeit und welt ist es
eigentlich offenbar doch eine bedürfnis
auch langsam zu erzählen und etwas
langsames zu erleben also ich weiß nicht
ob ihr eine episode von breaking bad in
erinnerung habt wo die hauptfigur ich
glaube eine ganze episode lang eine
fliege an der wand versucht so zu
erklatschen und man weiß eigentlich
nicht genau worauf sie hinaus geht und
trotzdem bleibt man dran es ist einfach
in dieser langsamkeit 1 1 ein jahr ein
bedürfnis da hinein zu tauchen
als kompensation mit einer schnellen
light oder werden bei uns was glaube ich
mir um geschichtliche absichtlich und
unter weil ich mich unendlich langweile
wenn ich vor dem fernseher sitze und die
szene verstanden habe und dann dauert
die einstellung aber noch 5 sekunden und
geschmeidig die schon innerlich und
denke es reicht ich habe es verstanden
jetzt und das ist nicht weil ich
ungeduldig bin weil ich bilder nicht
ertragen sondern weil da kommt nichts
mehr
und ich weiß dann auch oft dass man das
machen muss weil man irgendeinen
bestimmten soll an soll erfüllen sollte
so lange muss die serie gehen ach so
müssen wir halt die bilder noch ein
bisschen länger stehen lassen ich kenne
ja ich arbeite ja auch beim film und da
wird man manchmal auch langweilig und
dann denke ich auch warum um alles in
der welt müssen geschichten alle in so
einer angemieteten in einem angemieteten
tempo erzählt werden ich will jetzt mit
einer machen die überhaupt nicht
angemietet ist
ich sage ja immer wir sind die kleine
bank schwester von bestatter und von
wilder weil wir einfach auch mit sehr
viel weniger geld sehr viel schneller
sein mussten
und das hatte wirklich immer etwas von
punk wir wussten auch selten wie machen
wir das jetzt eigentlich da kommst du
irgendwo an sein hauptsache wir machen
jetzt das muss gut sein es muss schnell
sein
ich wollte etwas richtig schnelles
machen diesmal wissen sie was wir
schauen uns jetzt mal den anfang von
seiten trivial und da wird eigentlich
selbst erklärt worum es eigentlich geht
es gibt gründe um liebesgeschichte immer
so aus dass zwei sich kennenlernt und
aufhöre dann zusammen mit was geht es
nach erzählen natürlich dass sie werden
bald streitet sie haben zusammen die
breite guntram überbreite man das im
volk so schlimm ist zum glück nicht
erwartet
als kursleiter immer so schöne zeit
ich bin ja sehr dankbar ist der anfang
von der rücksitz bistum je passiert ist
die von union meppen werden
die schlacht geschlagen
[Musik]
die gleiche thema ist dann
der kollektive wenn sich kommen sie bis
an die zukunft
perspektive
jeder christ mit dem und aufwerten
und das wetter ist schneller
[Musik]
ja klar
vom
[Musik]
ein los
bai/sda
[Musik]
von grey
in der klasse
essen
china
[Musik]
ja man erkennt sich da leicht wieder die
hosen sie diesen stoff in einer serie
behandeln und nicht in einem fehlen ja
gute frage
ich hatte diesen stoff schon länger in
arbeit musste aber tatsächlich nicht in
welcher form die standardmaße diskussion
das als bühnenstück zu machen
das wäre dann natürlich völlig anders
visuell anders aufgelöst worden
aber dann habe ich erfahren dass srf
basieren stoffe sucht und dachte warum
eigentlich nicht weil das für mich doch
fast alle typisch ist als serie zu
erzählen
du hast ein ensemble von leuten es sind
nicht ganz viele es ist ein
überschaubares ausnahme von leuten du
kannst jeweils in die einzelnen paare
hineingehen du kannst mal die erzählen
mir drei paare in der geschichte plus
noch 2 3 so satelliten sage ich einzelne
aber du kannst mal zu diesem paar mal zu
diesem mal zu diesem und du kannst bei
allen dreien schauen wie organisieren
die in ihren langzeitbeziehungen sex und
liebe also das begehren das am anfang so
ist wie wir es jetzt gesehen haben was
ja nach zehn jahren unmöglich dasselbe
sein kann auch nicht soll ist auch nicht
schlimm wie organisieren sich paare ihr
begehren das war die frage und ich
glaube dass man das sehr gut seriell
erzählen kann indem man zu den
verschiedenen paaren hüpft man kann
verschiedene perspektiven erzählen das
ist eigentlich dass man nimmt kann auch
die perspektiven der verschiedenen leute
einnehmen
und es gibt diese verschiedenen figuren
schaffen wiederum verschiedene
anknüpfungspunkte man hört auch von
manchen zuschauern dass sie sich ganz
stark
ja also mit einer figur wie gianni
identifizieren oder es gibt natürlich
dann auch die älteren frauen die sagen
eine frauenfigur wie die klarer die eben
sex mit jungen männern hat finden sie
eigentlich noch interessant wenn
verschiedene anknüpfungspunkte und
verschiedene perspektiven
da kommt natürlich auch dazu dass wir in
suite jungen erzählen wir einen längeren
zeitraum gehen wo du beim film das alles
hat das zusammensuchen müssen dann wäre
es unglaubwürdig geworden das wollte ich
ihnen sagen weil die figuren durchlaufen
eine entwicklung die nicht nicht
wirklich diese unterschiedlichen
perspektiven sondern auch die die
entwicklung die gezeigt wird und auch
sozusagen diese anknüpfung an den alltag
an das alltägliche das scheint neben
diesen kollektiven dem er gezeigt werden
diesen service bei serien eben auch so
ein charakteristikum zu sagen und sie
schreiben es geht in dieser serie auch
darum um das aushalten der eigenen
durchschnittlichkeit was meinen sie
damit ja ich glaube wenn man wenn man
einen menschen neu kennenlernt sich
verliebt ist der interessanteste moment
nicht der dass man den anderen so toll
findet sondern dass der andere einem das
gefühl gibt dass man so toll sei ich
glaube es ist dieses gefühl war sein so
süchtig macht und man hat plötzlich ist
man die idealste version die es von
einem selbst geben kann und in diesem
raum lebt man vor sich hin und denkt
endlich bin ich da angekommen wo ich hin
weil das sagen verliebte menschen oft
sie sagen ich bin angekommen
sie sind bei sich angekommen bei der
perfektesten version in der sie geben
kann und irgendwann merkst du das stimmt
nicht ganz so weite alltag reinkommt ist
überhaupt nicht schlimm ist aber es ist
halt so
du merkst die kleinen dinge die doch
nicht ganz stimmen die nicht so perfekt
sind
du merkst plötzlich du steuererklärungen
zusammen ausfüllen das ist nicht sehr
glamourös soll es auch nicht dann kommen
die ersten ernüchterungen die
ernüchterungen zeigen dir du bist nicht
dieser perfekte diese perfekte gesehen
die du gerne wärs dann projiziert du das
auf deinen partner weil denkt er ist ja
schuld dass ich so bin weil wenn er sich
nicht immer so benehmen würde wäre ich
ja noch die perfekte version von mir
dann fängt das an diese zuzuweisen
ausgesprochen oder nicht
manche denken sie auch nur und dann
beißt sich das romantische richtig 7
ich glaube daran daran sieht man noch
mal was das eigene ist in den serien
dass man eben die möglichkeit hat nicht
nur eine figur lang zu entwickeln
sondern andere auch und entwickeln heißt
immer schwächen aufzeigen und diese
schwächen überwinden
und wenn wir sehen dass nicht nur eine
figur schwächen hat wie ich das im
normalen leben auch ab sondern andere
auch dann wird das andere das ganze sehr
menschlich und wenn es sehr menschlich
wird dann fangen wir an uns damit zu
identifizieren weil wir auch so sein
weil wir halt auch wissen dass wir
fehler haben aber wir können sie da in
dieser in dieser anderen welt miterleben
ja und um die die figuren sind ja ganz
zentral auch für die geschichten selbst
sondern wirklich so ich das gelesen habe
eine geschichte soll nicht in figuren
aufgestellt werden sondern soll sich an
den rollen selbst entwicklung aber damit
man dann wirklich auch dran bleibt
braucht es eben diese cliffhanger ich
schon gesprochen haben und wir schauen
uns mal ein beispiel ausbilder an
nämlich den schluss der dritten folge wo
man verschiedene personen noch mal sieht
und am schluss kommt nochmals eine neue
spur
damit man auch wirklich dranbleibt
[Musik]
mühlacker
kassel
sie lacht
ja welche elemente seines denn die
besonders geeignet sind und diese
spannung zu erzeugen herbert ja nicht
also spannung erzeugt man sich ja mal in
erster linie in dem man auch wieder mit
den hauptfiguren sich identifiziert
indem man einen er schon aufgebaut hat
weil dann fürchtet man sich um sie dann
bangt man um diese figur dann ist sicher
wichtig dass man fragen stellt und eben
nicht beantwortet also hier kommen neue
fragen auf was hat der damit zu tun was
könnte die gerade in diesem moment
denken und dieses sind alles figuren
wenn man das jetzt nicht gesehen hat
weiß man es nicht aber es ist die dritte
episode man hat schon gewisse figuren
entwickelt und es gehen neue fragen auf
weil alle eigentlich irgendwie mit der
sache zu tun haben
und das erzeugt natürlich spannung weil
wir wissen wollen wie es weitergeht das
ist auch dann eine zuschauerbindung
natürlich ganz klar wir wollen das jetzt
unbedingt wissen wie es weitergeht und
und ein glaube ich wichtigste spannungs
erzeuger ist glaube ich so spence also
wenn der zuschauer mehr weiß als die
hauptfigur im film selbst wenn also die
hauptfigur in ein haus in ein dunkles
haus hinein geht es ist schon eine
gefährliche stimmung wie als zuschauer
wissen der mörder ist irgendwo hinter
der tür aber der schauspieler oder die
hauptfigur weiß das nicht dann fürchten
wir um sie und hoffen dass dass sie
überlebt und nun das erzeugt glaube ich
die größte spannung das ist ja seit
hitchcock ganz klar ein starkes modell
und vielleicht auch diese gefühle von
furcht und mitleiden mit bangen da kann
man wahrscheinlich bis zu aristoteles
zurückgehen oder mit diesen elementen
spielen wahrscheinlich viele serien ja
das ist alle geschichten eigentlich also
alle dramatischen erzählungen ob das auf
dem theater ist oder den romanen es ist
auch so dass es dann zwar etwas ist aber
es geht tatsächlich um
mitleiden als um empathie um
identifikation
es geht um furcht oder so dass man was
erhofft für die figur oder für die figur
was befürchtet und es geht natürlich am
schluss auch also das ich erlebt das
selber auch als manchmal fast eine
physiologische reaktion wenn ich
spannende serien gucken
und wenn ich mit den figuren somit gehe
ich merke wie ich also ich komme auch
ins schwitzen maximal oder oder ich
werde nervös und ich wünsche mir so sehr
was für die und ich bin wahnsinnig
erleichtert wenn es dann auch so kommt
oder auch total schockiert wenn es nicht
so kommt also es gibt auch die form von
spannung aber auch entspannung oder und
das ist dann eben dass die frage nach
der katalog der reinigung von diesen
emotionen die man da so stark erlebt hat
dass man hinterher auch sagen kann
durchatmen kann sein
entweder ich hab was gelernt oder ich
habe wahnsinnig was gefühlt also
offenbar haben wir auch starke das
starke bedürfnis in unserer zeit nach
großen emotionen also das ist etwas was
mich bei serienchef woran liegt das
ich glaube wir suchen nach beständigkeit
in einer manchmal unbeständigen welt
versuchen eben wie gesagt auch nach halt
und wir suchen glaube ich ich habe es
vor eingangs schon mal gesagt ich glaube
wir versuchen diese gefühle
anstelle dieser leute nach zu empfinden
weil sie wie sie vielleicht den im
alltag selber uns gar nicht eingestehen
zu haben oder vergessen haben dass wir
sie haben
und da löst da kommt etwas heraus wofür
dann sehr dankbar sind und dieses gefühl
von dankbarkeit oder gerührt hat ist
glaube ich wirklich ein ganz starkes
bedürfnis
wir dürfen ja auch ganz oft gar nicht
dass ja auch wir sind ja sehr
kontrolliert stellen sie sich mal vor
wir würden all unseren emotionen freien
lauf lassen
das ist man könnte natürlich auch die
these aufstellen dass man sagt wir sind
so angepasst und so funktionieren so
sehr
in diesem mittlerweile doch relativ in
einem sehr geordneten system und da gibt
es eben auch irgendwie ganz archaische
wünsche nach jagd vorher ja die großen
fragen leben und tod
die die man immer ein bisserl ausblendet
mit denen wird man durch solch
geschichten zum teil konfrontiert wird
trotzdem sagen das ist nicht nur ich bin
einverstanden mit dem was er sagt über
die inhalte und die identifikations
momente aber ich würde es trotzdem noch
eine stufe daraus nehmen und sagen
es spielt bei serien eine ganz große
rolle dass man im moment das schauend
diese intimität hat viele gegner mit dem
laptop ins bett die gehen nicht wie
sieht's nicht auf die sofas richten
schauen am fernsehen bei uns ist es
hierzu bei seitentriebe ist es so dass
die leute zu zweit weil seine paar
geschichte ist zu zweit also ein laptop
neben ins bett gehen sich das anschauen
und dann vielleicht auch so was wie ein
eskapismus einen ersten ich bin jetzt
mal ganz bei mir ich möchte von dieser
welt da draußen nicht zu wissen
ich möchte jetzt mir das können das ist
so eine art classico wellnessoase ich
schaue dass jetzt ich habe das für mich
entdeckt und das gehört mir und dann
aber trotzdem raus gehen und die anderen
also sozusagen die gleich die die die
wie sagt man die die selbsthilfegruppe
die das dann auch gesehen hat und mit
denen darüber sprechen das muss nicht
körperlich nahe sein
das kann ja auch übers netz passieren
ist er meistens auf twitter oder auf
facebook oder in den leserkommentaren
oder zuschauer kommentaren und ich
glaube dass das sehr viel ausmacht
dieses ding ich habe etwas für mich
gefunden was mir gut tut was sie schauen
möchte ich möchte in diesem ding auch
experte werden es gibt ganz viele serien
experten auch leute die sehr viel wissen
ich glaube es hat ein bisschen das
musikwissen abgelöst wie in den 90ern
war musik wissen noch sehr gefragt man
musste alle bands kennen und wird von
david bowies die entfernteste platte
irgendwo raus holen konnte
die versteckte sste das war der könig
und heute gibt man ja ein bisschen an
indem man serien guckt die keiner kennt
trotzdem eine gewisse relevanz haben und
sozusagen das wesen der heutigen zeit
vielleicht anfangen die damals die musik
ich weiß war hat sie die serie diese
ganz unbekannte serie von millionen
anderen auch geguckt aber es muss in der
ihm eigenen bekanntenkreisen nicht
bekannt sein so dass man sagen
ich gucke aber was ganz anderes ich hab
da was entdeckt man gilt so ein bisschen
als cool wenn man für sich
abwegige serien entdeckt das habe ich
festgestellt
gibt es auch aber ich glaube es ist eben
wie du sagst auch so dass auch gesagt
bildet man kann es ist auch
gemeinschaftsstiftende ist tatsächlich
wieder was wo man sich über die gleichen
sachen unterhält ist es einerseits der
eskapismus das alleine gucken aber es
ist auch das ganze beziehungsnetz also
eben serien gehören mittlerweile in dem
freundeskreis mit dazu über die man gern
über die man spricht was wird passieren
spekulationen aber interessant ist dass
man sich dann erzählt wie sehr man
vielleicht gerührt war und wie sehr man
vielleicht geholt hat da zurückgezogen
im bett aber man sollte nicht zusammen
also es ist dann doch nicht dass man
nebeneinander rollen es ist nicht die
fußball weltmeisterschaft wo 10.000
leute im stadion zusammen jubeln und
sich dort verbunden fühlen
man macht es für sich allein und ich
glaube das ist schon auch ein spiegel
davon dass wir uns eben für diese großen
gefühle dann doch ein bisschen schämen
oder wir sind da wir sind da einfach
auch sehr kontrolliert und machen das
dann halt lieber alleine auf unserem
laptop aber dass laura schaut manchmal
auch mit zwei laptops übel dass sie das
nun charme moment ist ja es ist eine
mischung also ich glaube es ist es ist
schade dabei ich habe gesagt im kino
kann ich besser meinen gefühlen freien
lauf lassen wenn nicht meine frau oder
meine freunde da sitzen einfach weil ich
mich dann mehr gehen lassen kann es
kennt mich nicht mehr ich kann mehr
eintauchen
ich liebe es aus dem kino rauszugehen
und noch eine halbe stunde durch die
straßen zu laufen und diesem gefühl nach
platz zu lassen wenn ich dann schon fünf
minuten später mit allen darüber reden
muss verschwindet dieses gefühl ich
glaube ich will das teilen aber ich
würde schon sagen
darauf an welche von welcher serie man
spricht dass man das natürlich eine
komödiantische heitere geschichte ist
dann kann man nicht häufig zu sehr gut
zusammen gucken und dann darüber reden
und bei seitentriebe ist das klar dass
es gibt diese tragischen momente
elemente entwicklung aber eigentlich ist
das sehr heiter von der anlage her und
beim bestatter ist das ja auch so weil
er bei der grossen schweizer serie dass
da viele komische momente drin sind und
auch diverse figuren sind für diese
serie ganz wichtig ist eben nicht nur
dekoration also irgendwie andere auch
ganz entscheidung wir schauen uns jetzt
noch ein kurzer ausschnitt die starter
an wo auch der rechtsmediziner
allerdings selber weiß vorkommt nach der
bestattungen sind aus der mode
jedoch ist sie für bestattungen und
prüfungsstoff als passionierter
totengräber kennst ihn braucht nicht so
wie das brave das berühmte herzblut
dahinter augustinerkirche in wien ja gut
jetzt hat sie auch keine ups bürger was
ich jetzt mit deiner herz bestätigen
die herzen kann man ins herz kriftel die
eingeweihten den stephansdom und die
körper die kapuzinergruft du wieder alle
was davon haben jetzt verstehen
vielleicht deshalb ich ausgewandert bin
du glaubst du dass davon auch sich das
opfer über die hauptstadt verteilt
kann man nur hoffen denn ohne den rest
dieses bedauernswerten menschen werden
wir das nicht wohl nie erfahren
das baby skelett im kunsthaus eine
postkarte und des menschen herz im glas
direkt zu mir gewartet es könnte aber
einfach normale spiele pausieren was
wirklich nicht überreagieren
theoretisch habe es einfach los geht's
der durst auf der höhe nach frankreich
wo wir wahnsinnig viel geld dafür die
ganze truppe und zwar bevor das ist ja
schon abgeschlachtet
ich war wieder ostern screen mit der
post ach ja frau aber mich interessiert
wie man so etwas schreibt da es gibt
dabei keine starter wie bei vielen
anderen serien immer zwei geschichten
die eine rolle spielen nämlich einen die
sich über die folgen hinweg für eine
ganze staffel und sagen erzählt wird und
eine die innerhalb einer folge zum
abschluss gibt wie verhalten sich dann
diese beiden zueinander diese beiden
geschichten schreiben tue ich das ja
nicht wir haben tolle autoren dafür und
bei dem beim bestatter ist es ein
writers room system mit dem wir arbeiten
also eine mehrere writers room also
sitzen werden autoren wirklich
miteinander eingesperrt beim bestatter
sind das wächst also hatten wir
jahrelang zwei autoren die quasi die
geschichte von anfang bis ende
durchgeplant haben also die die
handlungsbögen wohin sollen sich die
figuren entwickeln was gibt es für
einzelfälle aber auch was ist was sind
die die hauptfiguren auf dem
durchgehenden fall
und dann kamen zusätzlich weitere
autoren dazu oft nachwuchsautoren dann
später die einzelnen folgen auch
geschrieben haben wenn die story schon
stand und bei dieser fünften staffel
haben es gerade in ausschnitt gesehen
haben haben wir eigentlich das war die
horizontale am stärksten da gibt es
folgen da gibt es gar keinen einzelnen
fall mehr zum beispiel diese folge ist
eine um dieses herz auftaucht und die
gehört zum horizontal fall und es geht
nur darum in dieser folge
ich meine ein faktor über den wir jetzt
noch nicht gesprochen haben aber über
den wir sprechen sollten wenn wir in die
zukunft blicken und wie in zukunft
serien serien geschrieben werden dann
sind das daten und algorithmen also für
die bekannte serie house of cards wurde
da schon eingesetzt der schauspieler
kevin spacey wurde von einem algorithmus
sozusagen vorgeschlagen und auch das
weiße haus als austria ort wo das ganze
spielt und dass dieses big data in
zukunft auch für die serienwelt immer
wichtiger wird das sagt der
social-media-experte
manuel napo das heißt das house of cards
the machine die erste serie ist wo es
der kunde wünscht vielleicht sogar
latent der wind später dürfen ist vom
hund präferenz von rund kreierte schon
nicht umgekehrt also sehr sehr eu
staaten entstanden ist und datenanalyse
und nicht um kreatives genie firmenauto
ja heißt das dass in zukunft die serien
vielleicht macht man algorithmen
geschrieben werden und dass die
publikums daten immer wichtiger werden
ich glaube so neu ist das ja nicht also
ich denke mal die großen produzenten in
hollywood haben immer auch natürlich
danach getrachtet was die leute mögen
man kann es einfach heute besser
erfassen weil man es digital messen kann
und so
deshalb glaube ich schon dass das etwas
ist das
stärker vorkommen wird ich weiß halt
nicht ob man geschichten berechnen kann
oder die unberechenbarkeit eines
menschen berechnen ich hoffe es nicht
also das wäre dann schon ziemlich dunkel
ich denke es wird weiterhin daten werden
weiterhin gesammelt man wird weiterhin
solche dinge tun aber man wird
schauspieler eben damit aussuchen themen
aussuchen
aber was den menschen in diesen
geschichten passiert ich glaube dass und
ihre schwächen und ihre fehler und ihre
irrationalen entscheide ich glaube das
können zum glück wie moment computer
noch nicht ja es gibt schon es gibt laut
maschinen die gibt es aber schon länger
als sicher auf der filmakademie in
ludwigsburg war war das sehr beliebt als
jux er noch mit diesen plot maschinen zu
arbeiten weil sie einen dauernd
irgendwas vorgeschlagen haben wir haben
es wirklich so als pausenfüller
angesehen wussten gar noch nicht was
daraus entstehen würde
es gibt inzwischen sehr sehr gute plot
maschinen sogar die die wirklich
komplette geschichte liefern also die
sagen du brauchst hier noch eine figur
sonst wirst du da nicht raus kommen
du brauchst du eine weibliche junge
figur die dann irgendwie das und das und
das macht und an dieser stelle wieder
verschwinden muss muss zum verschwinden
kannst du eingeben welche möglichkeiten
habe ich wie sie verschwinden muss also
es gibt da schon recht ausgeklügeltes
zeug was wie gesagt bei uns noch
taschenspielertricks waren und
inzwischen weiß ich aber dass große
häuser sehr wohl mit plot maschinen
arbeiten wie die heißen weiß ich jetzt
nicht da gibt's wahrscheinlich
verschiedene systeme auch ich hätte kein
problem damit wenn serien so entwickelt
werden sollen sie drehung programme gibt
es auch mehrere programme gibt es auch
ja ich glaube aber es im kern braucht es
trotzdem immer ein autor und würde auch
gern vorher noch ergänzen was es zu den
verschiedenen arbeitsweisen von alleine
schreiben oder auch in reiters schreiben
was es immer braucht es ist eine vision
es geht jetzt nicht um irgendeine es
geht darum dass man gemeinsam weiß was
man erzählen will und dass man das es
geht dabei nicht um kompromiss sondern
division muss was ganz eigenes was ganz
originelles auch sein und je länger ein
autor es schafft eine geschichte zu sich
selbst also aussicht zu schöpfen
ob als team oder als einzelne desto
spezifischer ist die geschichte und das
du besonderer und desto mehr weiß er
worüber er was zu erzählen hat und
solange das menschen gibt die was zu
erzählen haben hoffe ich dass der glaube
ich hoffe ich inständig dass nicht die
maschinen irgendwann die geschichten
erzählen weil das wäre für mich wirklich
der totalitarismus das wäre dann werden
uns nur noch die geschichten erzählt die
wir wollen die geschichten
wir müssen aber auch geschichten zu
lassen und hören die fragen stellen die
uns irritieren die uns zum lernen
auffordern
und dann sind wir irgendwann selbst der
computer das ist ja vielleicht die
logische notorische ende von uns
irgendwann aber oder wir werden besser
weißt du wenn du sagst es gibt diese
ganzen computer die das können was wir
jetzt können oder in etwa
dann wäre doch die reaktion darauf nicht
sehr gut den höheren jedoch auf sondern
wir machen das was wir können nämlich
genau dieses unberechenbare dieses nicht
nach logik funktionierender das machen
ja ihr schon die ganze zeit
menschenfiguren den film machen dinge
denkt wieso machen die bis jetzt
und irgendwann drei folgen später kommt
die erklärung warum er das gemacht hat
manchmal kommt es auch gar nicht ich
liebe solche sachen die einfach nicht
durch erklärt sind nicht menschen sind
so menschen sind sie machen komische
sache und das finde ich glaube wir
müssen uns dann er vielmehr noch in
diese abteilung bewegen und sagen dann
machen wir eben das was uns eigentlich
auch am meisten spaß macht lassen sie
uns zum schluss noch ein bisschen auf
die gegenwart blicken schauen welche
trends da sind und mich würde
interessieren was sie derzeit gucken was
so dass neue ist was erscheint am
horizont was sie mir empfehlen würden
was ich unbedingt sehen
müsste was wäre das zum schloss ich
empfehle zum beispiel brot church eine
serie die uns auch inspiriert hat bilder
zu schreiben eine geschichte eine
krimigeschichte aber es ist eine
dramatische geschichte eine geschichte
wo das trauern im vordergrund steht wo
die familie im vordergrund steht und
vordergrund steht leuten hinter den
vorhang zu blicken und schauen wie es
eigentlich zu und her gibt wie wir es
eben vor dem vorhang nicht sehen und
gleichzeitig ist darüber ein krimi vor
gestrickt das hat mich sehr berührt
damals und finde ich immer noch
wegweisend für diese art von krimi
geschichte
und dann gibt es natürlich die großen
klassiker die man auch sehen finde ich
sehen sollte sopranos ist immer noch
meiner meinung nach so ein bisschen die
mutter dieser qualitativ hochstehenden
fernsehserien wo es eben auch nicht um
die mafia geht nicht um korruption und
geld schon als setting aber eigentlich
geht es um etwas viel gefährlicheres
nämlich eben familie und pubertierende
kinder und eine eifersüchtige ehefrau
oder eine böse schwiegermutter wo es um
diese probleme geht und da findet man
auch wieder nähe zu den figuren und das
ist sicher sehr empfehlenswert was ist
für sie die beste serie jeweils
beschrieben wurde oder was würden sie
mir empfehlen die beste serie
tatsächlich die kleinen strolche
so etwas habe ich nie wieder gesehen das
war etwas was es eigentlich nicht geben
kann
aber so mit dem hund und dies die diese
diese völlig unterschiedlichen kinder
aus den 20er jahren ist das ja noch
und was ich aber an modernen serien ganz
toll wenn die ist auch bot ich finde ich
so beängstigend gut gemacht beängstigend
gut geschrieben dann fand ich aber auch
ich bin im moment eher so in deutschland
unterwegs jetzt zum gucken was es gibt
ich habe dort gesehen auf netflix war
hin und weg ist eine sehr düstere serie
sehr düster ich liebe so düstere sachen
ich selber cook ja gar nicht so viel
kommuniziert
düster beängstigend irgendwie in einer
zwischenwelt das hat mich sehr sehr sehr
leid tue
auch durch die machart ich fand auch
dass die mit der musik toll gearbeitet
haben
dann gibt es die neue serie von von
wissen langsam schluss kommen der
sendung von schwachen von christians
woche den titel ich für bad banks
was ist das für sie frau bei
lieblingsserie also twin peaks six feet
under gehört auf jeden fall dazu protsch
dort auf jeden fall auch dazu neue
unbedingt gucken babylon berlin hat ist
auch ein kosmos in dem man total gerne
einen tag was muss ich unbedingt sehen
zum beispiel in berlin also als neues
und ansonsten six feet under
vielen herzlichen dank für das gespräch
ja die abstimmung über die mobile
initiative ist vorbei aber die
diskussion dreht sich weiter was ist die
aufgabe von öffentlichen medien sind sie
noch die vierte macht im staat und
brauchen hier diese macht darüber
diskutierte nächste philosophische
stammtisch am 4
april im sud in basel tickets dafür gibt
es jetzt auf unserer webseite nächste
woche spreche ich mit dem schriftsteller
peter stamm über das schicksal und die
frage was mit unserem eigenen leben
passiert wenn wir es als kunstwerk als
normal betrachten und jetzt gleich
zeigen wir einen film über die
süditalienische stadt matera früher
nannte man sie eine nationale schande
bald aber wird sie die europäische
kulturhauptstadt sein warum das erfahren
sie jetzt bleiben sie also dran und
einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]